we're unveiling a new feature tonight on
the angle so gather the children around
the television because it's time for
reading with kjp
[Music]
how confident are you that the big rate
hike yesterday will tap down on
inflation so here's here's what i will
say is that we understand what every
what what american families are going
through
as you know uh this has been a priority
uh bringing down an inflation and why
isn't the president asking oil companies
to drill more here in the u.s let me
just let me just give you a little bit
of a rundown of why we are here oil
refineries have still not brought
refinery capacity back to the
pre-pandemic levels at the same time
putin's invasion of ukraine put pressure
on global supply
and gas prices have gone up by nearly
two dollars since before the invasion
given the rising interest rates for
mortgages can you see if the white house
is concerned about housing affordability
so we know that housing affordability is
essential as a central challenge for
families the president understands that
and this is why he's put forward the
housing supply action plan
[Music]
well according to this white house joe
biden has not just saved the us economy
he has it humming
but what's the reality well the atlanta
fed now says that second quarter gdp
growth will be
wait for it
zero
the philly fed index slipped into
contraction territory in june for the
first time since the coveted lockdowns
and speaking at first because we all
love firsts the dow was down sharply on
recession fears closing below 30
thousand for the first time since
january twenty twenty one hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else